it's so funny because you've done uh so
much work I mean I've seen obviously uh
you know Breaking Bad and uh the work
you're doing on your honor and you've
done I saw you on Broadway as as Lyndon
Johnson uh and and you killed it you've
sort of
conquered all these different worlds and
I always go back to it's funny every now
and then I run into a Malcolm in the
Middle
and you're it's one of the funniest
performances I've seen on television uh
you as how and it's a very particular
kind of uh almost cartoonish energy I'm
not going to say almost that you're
bringing to that role and there are so
many little ticks but the physicality of
it is absolutely hilarious and so I
started to I came to that show later
uh I think when Malcolm in the Middle
was was really you know hitting on all
cylinders I'm working on The Late Night
show and I'm thinking well that's a
family show for kids I'm not really
paying attention
and then I went back and I started
seeing some of them later on in reruns
and then I started noticing that there
are fans that do like mashups of all of
your most amazing sequences and I can
watch those forever I can watch those
forever because I maintain that your
shriek as Hal is one of the funniest
things I've ever seen and also you
running you run away
funnier than anyone in comedy I think
your runaway is absolutely delightful
does that make sense to you your runaway
want to see it
there are so many scenes where Hal is up
against it and you're if you decide to
run away and you know you you do this
thing where every part of your body is
moving kind of incorrectly it's like
there's 35 cats inside a person's suit
trying to run away and it is so
hilarious that's the kind of stuff I
think physical comedy when people can
nail that I think you're in a just a
high Stratosphere that most people don't
get to experience and I just I can watch
that stuff forever that was that was an
interesting uh job for me because
everything else was cast the entire
family was already cast and they
couldn't find the dad in the pilot
episode I think I have three or four
lines and that's it and so I was trying
to find the core of every character that
I do I look for what's at the emotional
Center of this person and I'm looking
for different ways and I finally come
came across it and I realized oh well
just keep this simple I I wrote down all
the qualities that the Jane casmeric
character who played Lois had
fierce
tough resilient and I go oh Fierce a
wimp tough soft resilient you know
cracks cracks immediately yeah and I
started I just went just the complete
opposite and one of the that I came to
is her was fearless and I went oh he's
frightened
that's it he's frightened of everything
and so once I grabbed onto that
everything in his life he's frightened
about being fired about being a bad
parent about uh you know his wife
leaving him about you know about spiders
about Heights about it it's like you
know he was frightened about everything
and from that point everything kind of
grew and where did the shriek come from
because it's
so much fun there was a sequence I saw
once where
you've gotten into
um what is it called race walking yes
you got into race walking and you think
someone else is more jogging than race
walking one of your teammates or
competitors and you accuse him and then
he panics and he tries to race walk away
and you say don't worry I've got this
and you start race walking after him
when you could just run
and I look at it and I am not uh you
know some people say well to really see
classic
comedy you need to look back at chaplain
you need to look at Laura and hurney I
think yes definitely true but you you
see it all over the place you just have
to be looking for it there are people
that can do it uh and obviously that was
a really great idea so I give the
writers credit the director but
um but that character is one of the
funniest characters in television I
think they still endures you know it's
so God I haven't seen it in ages so I
mean it's I I hope I hope it does and I
I have new generations of people coming
up to me because it plays on Disney
Channel I think and they they said my
kids are now watching I loved it when I
was kidding now my kids are watching
this and it's like that
that's good when it can endure what's
also fascinating that you could be how
and then
you know uh you can be Walter White and
I know that I think one of the things
that that I always realized is there is
um there's great comedy there's it's a
different kind of comedy can be very
dark but there's really funny moments
between you and Aaron Paul there's
really funny moments in your life trying
to make this transformation trying to go
through this but if you look at the work
that you're doing on Malcolm in the
Middle and you're taking it you're
playing way up that end of the neck on
the guitar and then you look at the the
the finale of Breaking Bad and you see
where you've gone and you think
the it's impossible to imagine it's it's
crazy it's a it's a crazy range and and
in this town most uh people want to be
able to place you as doing something oh
Conan well he's comedy guy and he
doesn't I never get that you never get
that
I get he's trying really hard and he's
well intentioned that's what I was into
no but exactly yeah they want to they
want to Pigeon hold you in that so one I
did seven years of Malcolm in the Middle
and it was great and out of that I had a
couple offers to do a sweet goofy dad on
a sitcom right after that and I thought
how could I do something different at
this moment it's so ingrained I need to
completely step away from that world so
easily said no to that
and later that year uh same year uh I
got it I got a notice I said well you
did a an episode of X-Files about nine
years ago before Malcolm in the Middle
and the writer of that episode Vince
Gilligan would like to see you about
this show called Breaking Bad you
remember him I said nope
hard pass
I'm not gonna go audition and I said
sure uh and and I read it and it was
just incredible and what Vince did and
what he said he wanted to do at the
outset is he wanted to change the main
character
throughout the course of the series
which has never been done in series
television if you look at Archie Bunker
or Tony Soprano or whomever they they
are the same people they react to
different stimulus but they are the same
person whereas Walter White was going to
change from a good honest guy to
becoming a killer yeah as as Vince
Gilligan often says he said I just want
to see if I can change a guy from Mr
Chips to Scarface they're not going to
let me I know they're just not going to
let me do it but oh we'll we'll see what
it can we can do you know he's such a
sweet unassuming God yeah Vince Gilligan
I've had the uh the joy of hanging with
him a little bit and you would never
sense that he was the creative Center of
you know the best TV show ever he
doesn't act that way if I had achieved
what he had achieved I'd be wearing an
Admirals
hats I'd have epaulettes I'd be carried
around yes I'm one of those chairs uh I
would let everyone know uh but um it's
it's really uh it's really amazing when
you look at uh and it's you know I it's
funny because you probably heard this
from a lot of people
I went back uh because my son never saw
breaking bad he was too young but we
started watching it together and I went
back to the beginning and it's
mind-blowing because
I know the transition that's going to
happen because I've watched every
episode of the show when it was on but
now I'm starting again and I still can't
believe it's gonna happen oh you know
what I mean you still think no no this
is on some level it's you're you know I
don't see how that what could possibly
happen yet there's not a false note
along the way and and you know it's that
old saying that uh
uh whatever a a curve is an infinite
number of straight lines that it's like
no it is possible you just have to make
sure that the changes are very subtle
and each one has to be earned it has to
be earned and I think that's what's
magical about that is everything Walter
White does is earned yes and that's the
writing it is the writing it's uh I will
always say this because an actor gets
inspired through great writing and and
an actor can only perform
so much if an actor got
B level material
working at his or her best
I do believe I could get it up a grade
level
but if I got sea level material you're
getting a b out of me that's as all
that's as far as you can go
um it just it really does take in
incredible writing if you get a level
material you treat it like the Holy
Grail it's like oh my God oh my God oh
my God just don't screw this up you know
just oh my God and man Breaking Bad was
like that you're turning the pages and
going oh my God I cannot believe he's
doing this
oh my God and yet it's not
an aberration it's something that was
set up if you were attentive to it it it
does track if you go back and still it's
surprising to you hard to believe it's
been how many years has it been since
breaking bad and has it been eight years
you're looking off you could look at me
yeah
Walter White right here and you're
looking at me
right here I'm gonna try and find out
but wait I'll be back but no no Conan I
could I could tell you I'll head this
way
how many years has it been I don't know
God damn you damn you
2013. uh 2013 yeah
so that's been it's uh it's it's uh
someone do the math
um
well it depends on when this airs we're
holding on to this for a few years I
think people need to be ready for this
interview uh the way it started they
really need to be prepared we need to
clear yeah nine years so far so uh but
when you when you go back as as you've
done I don't think I'm spoiling anything
here uh to to pick up and and and have
these moments uh in Better Call Saul
is it does it feel like you're putting
on an old suit it does it feels like
that yep it's it's slipping you know how
uh for an actor when you sit in in the
in the chair and you start putting on
the makeup and you start looking at when
I did uh the HBO movie all the way where
I played LBJ it took three hours of
prosthetic makeup uh three hours every
morning and although I used it as my as
my preparation into getting into that
headspace to play that guy that big
boisterous domineering man and I can see
the transformation happening when I'm
looking in the mirror and they're
applying all the extra nose and the ears
and the things and and pretty soon you
start talking like this and God damn it
get out of here I mean where's my soda
you know and start poking people and you
go and you become that guy really helped
same thing with even putting on Walter
White's
desert boots and his khakis and his
shirt his long sleeve shirt and that you
know very very iconic pork pie hat of
his and there he is and you go
I I know what this feels like and then
you kind of it just kind of helps you
slip into that character and because all
this time has gone by and you've done
all these other things and the fact that
you can access it which you know I
imagine is
uh that's the craft well I imagine but
think if
uh for for a comedy tour that you did
yeah and a routine uh yeah you know yep
and if someone said remember this and
you go oh yeah yeah yeah and remember
this and remember this and then you
might pick up on it and go and then I
did this and I remember that yes and you
start it's it starts ticking away at
your brain and your memory starts coming
back and you start to be able to recite
certain lines from it you're going to be
rusty like you are in most of your shows
seems cruel and unusual